du pouvoir régional plus de trois ans
après une tentative de sécession à bord
tessier on a voté au kosovo également
des législatives anticipées sont
cinquièmes scrutins du genre depuis
l'auto proclamation de son indépendance
en 2008 le parti de gauche souverainiste
qui s'appuie sur la jeunesse est en tête
selon les sondages sorties des urnes
derrière lui la jeunesse qui semble
vouloir en finir avec les anciens
combattants qui dirige la provence
depuis 20 ans sous le feu des critiques
pour sa lenteur l'union européenne va
autoriser plus rapidement les vaccins
contre les variants elle va alléger la
procédure d'autorisation pour les
vaccins améliorée par un fabricant sur
la base d'un sérum déjà existants et
certifier une annonce de la commissaire
à la santé
et puis en france on sait que le variant
sud-africain circule activement en
moselle et dans le nord à dunkerque pour
autant pas de confinement localiser ni
fermeture des écoles dans ces régions
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue fée vous nous
rejoignez sur arte france on parle tout
de suite en catalogne où les bureaux de
vote ferment puisqu'il est un peu plus
de 20 heures les élections régionales
fin 6 millions le catalan étaient
appelés aux urnes pour élire les députés
chargée d'investir à un nouveau
président du parlement régional à car
depuis la destitution de klimt aura en
septembre dernier la catalogne doit donc
renouveler son gouvernement un scrutin
trois ans après la tentative de
sécession avortée des indépendantistes
en lice face au pouvoir socialiste de
madrid dirigée par le premier ministre
pedro sanchez
on va rejoindre sur place les flying là
bonsoir à vous comment fait passer cette
journée de vote
alors pour limiter les risques de
contagion une organisation rigoureuse et
est au point il y avait des horaires
réservées à chaque collectif alors de 9
heures à midi c'était réservé aux
personnes âgées aux personnes à risque
2010 à 19h c'était réservé au reste de
la population
puis de 19 heures à 20 heures c'était
les personnes affectées par le biais de
19 les personnes en quarantaine et les
cas contacts qui ont pu aller voter
alors à l'intérieur des bureaux de vote
les assesseurs avaient toutes les
protections nécessaires le port du
masque des gants une visière est aussi
une combinaison spéciale pour la
dernière heure
alors les électeurs étaient invités à
faire la queue dehors à respecter la
distance sociale de 2 mètres avec le
réseau très lecteurs mais aussi à
l'intérieur il devait faire donc très
attention et toujours pour favoriser la
distance sociale est limité à 500
électeurs dans les bureaux de vote la
catalogne avait habilités de nouveaux
endroits les gymnases bibliothèque et
marché couvert ont été transformés en
bureaux de vote pour l'occasion et elle
malgré toutes ces précautions le taux de
participation était fortement en baisse
à 18 heures en comparaison avec le
dernier scrutin de 2017
merci beaucoup l'esl et fo glas pour
toutes ces précisions
on poursuit les catalans ping était
plutôt réservé sur la tenue de ce
scrutin je vous propose d'écouter la
réaction de certains d'entre eux aux
abords à des bureaux de vote
je pense que le vote aurait dû soutenir
un peu plus tard mieux organisée et avec
plus de calme au bout du compte le
résultat sera ce qu'il doit être
j'espère que les choses vont changer
cela ne changera pas beaucoup quoi qu'il
arrive mais bon au moins cela permettra
de faire quelques petits pas malgré une
légère diminution du coc vide dans les
hôpitaux etc
je pense que c'est une bonne chose
plutôt le vote se tiendra mieux ce sera
je suis venu voter en étant très fâché
cette année très fâché parce qu'aucun
parti n'a tire mon attention
mais comme il y en a certains que je ne
veux pas voir gagner sans nommer
personne
je suis venu voter mais je suis très en
colère aujourd'hui je veux ton colère et
au kosovo on a voté a également pour les
législatives anticipées le cinquième
scrutin de genre depuis l'auto
proclamation de son indépendance en 2008
et selon les premiers sondages issu des
urnes le parti d'opposition de gauche
est en tête
il s'agit du mouvement autodétermination
d'albin kurti qui veut en finir avec la
vieille garde corps présente l'actuel
premier ministre je vous propose de les
écouter
aujourd'hui les citoyens du kosovo
exercent leur droit de vote
l'espoir est grand beaucoup de défis à
relever mais nous avons l'espoir que le
taux de participation sera élevé avec un
grand résultat pour la démocratie pour
la construction de l'état pour les
futurs développements et progrès
j'appelle tous les citoyens qui ont le
droit de vote et utiliser ce droit et a
voté aujourd'hui c'est leur jour
aujourd'hui ils vont exprimer leur libre
choix d'un scrutin marqué par la
mobilisation d'une jeunesse derrière le
mouvement souverainiste de gauche
regardez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on voit les enjeux géopolitiques et
stratégiques du scrutin avec alexis
troude auteur de l'ouvragé balkans la
fracture la base européenne du djihad
aux éditions xenia
moi j'ai très peur eux et mini accentue
sauter perd 10
pourquoi pour tout simplement ils ont
leurs principales bases qu'il a au
kosovo au coeur de l'europe
plus de 8000 hommes ils sont en
permanence c'est pour très longtemps
c'est la principale base militaire de
redéploiement des armées américaines
extérieur et puis deuxième fait le
kosovo regorge de richesses du sous-sol
alors du lignite du 5e tour mais aussi
de tous ces nouveaux matériaux
militaires
et si vous voulez c'est au regard de ses
richesses peut se joue là encore ce
qu'on appelait à l'époque le grand jeu
c'est une opposition entre les
américains qui soutiennent finalement
qu'aux et ses dirigeants kosovars
ils n'ont que des yeux du maine pour le
grand frère américain est en face les
autres pays et passons en serbie mais
serbie macédoine maintenant une partie à
bastille et le monténégro depuis
quelques mois qui eux de plus en plus se
tourner vers la russie
et donc c'est le principal danger
actuellement c'est-à-dire à nouveau la
guerre froide européen vladimir poutine
accuse les occidentaux d'utiliser la
sphère alexeï navalni pour tenter
d'endiguer la russie le président russe
s'est exprimé lors d'un entretien à la
chaîne russe rossiya 24
l'interview diffusée aujourd'hui alors
que se déroulait dans la journée à
moscou un rassemblement de soutien
notamment l épouse de l'opposant russe
moulias on écoute un extrait de
l'entretien pas pour doit notamment que
le de vos crédits en ce qui concerne le
fait que lors des manifestations ni
certains y participer pour d'autres
raisons que l'individu en question est
peut-être que vous avez raison c'est
ainsi en effet 11 n'a été publié mais il
ya une chose cet individu lui même né
signifie lise précisément maintenant au
moment dans tous les pays du monde y
compris chez nous les gens comment
à être fatigué a jubilé de l'irritation
et à éprouver donné que lentement
y compris au sujet de leurs conditions
de vie de leurs revenus ag oui ce n'est
qu'avec ni date night round 4
il ya certes des tensions entre la
russie et les pays occidentaux mais pas
seulement signe de l'amitié entre paris
et moscou des militaires russes et
français ont été élus mais ensemble plus
de deux siècles après leur mort il
s'agit de centaines de soldats du qatar
et des grognards napoléoniens tous
tombés lors de la retraite de russie en
1812 les détails avec verhaeghe hoffman
qui a assisté à la cérémonie ch unis
pour l'éternité
les soldats russes et français tombés
lors de la bataille de verdun en 1812
ont été inhumés le 13 février avec les
honneurs qui leur étaient dues non loin
du champ de bataille c'est aujourd'hui
c'est un vraiment absolument formidable
c'est extrêmement émouvant puisque le
grand-duc romanov et moi-même qui sommes
et amis et cousins 200 ans après des
combats d'une extrême violence entre les
soldats russes et français nous sommes
aujourd'hui réunis tous les deux pour
rendre les hommages les honneurs
militaires soldats russes et français et
les autres allant même tombe c'est
absolument magnifique et c'est une très
très bel exemple d'amitié franco russe
et c'est vraiment deux peuples qui ont
une histoire commune énorme qui ont aidé
eu des moments difficiles des chansons
de paix démons ans d'incertitude mais
ont toujours une relation une forte
amitié
à des époques clé j'espère que ce moment
que nous retrouvons ensemble puisse être
un exemple pour le futur jeu mais pour
les relations que tout le monde puisse
travailler ensemble et vivre comme nous
nous retrouvons mon cousin et moi
aujourd'hui
l'événement est le fruit des efforts de
la fondation pour le développement des
initiatives historique franco russes
dans le cadre du projet sur les traces
de la campagne 1812 un groupe
d'archéologues russes et français ont
découvert une fosse commune contenant
120 six dépouilles
il s'agit de soldats russes et français
qui ont péri lors de la retraite de la
grande armée de napoléon la bataille
devait sma fut une défaite décisive de
la campagne de russie qui a précédé la
catastrophe de la bérézina pour moi
c'est le symbole vraiment le symbole
suprême de l'amitié franco-russe puisque
d'enterrer des soldats russes et
français mais qui se sont fait la guerre
qui a été émis à 208 ans et aujourd'hui
qu'ils reposent en paix c'est déjà un
signe historique et de l'amitié
franco-russe très très fort et la
deuxième chose c'est qu'avec tout le
climat politique actuel entre la france
la russie tous les problèmes que nous
avons c'est un et c'est un événement
historique diplomatique mais surtout
positif et ça c'est très important
maintenant les gens ils vont comprendre
en russie on honore les soldats russes
mais aussi français cette même fondation
est à l'origine de la découverte en 2019
de la tombe du général guy d'un proche
de napoléon plus de deux cents ans après
sa mort près de smolensk
ce fidèle de l'empereur va rejoindre son
ami et sevrin aux invalides le 5 mai
la cérémonie des funérailles se tiendra
le jour de 200 ans de la mort de
napoléon en présence de vladimir poutine
emmanuel macron voilée
soldats français et russes reposent
désormais en paix inséparables deux
siècles après en conflits meurtriers
comme l'a déclaré le descendant du
maréchal murat
lors de la cérémonie d'inhumation que
votre paie soit aussi celle de nos
peuples que votre fraternité sera aussi
celle de nos nations
un moment d'unité dans la france et la
russie en grand besoin
donald trump a été acquitté hier soir au
terme de son deuxième procès en
destitution durant cinq jours les
sénateurs démocrates ont tenté en vain
de prouver sa responsabilité dans
l'assaut à du capitole le 6 janvier
dernier
les précisions avec maxime abolin 57
sénateurs ont voté pour 43 ont voté
contre les faits d'accusation impliquant
l'ancien président donald trump pour
incitation à l'insurrection
donald trump est acquitté des charges à
son encontre il a manqué dix voix au
camp démocrate pour condamner donald
trump l'ancien président des états unis
a été acquitté lors de son second procès
en destitution devant le sénat il était
accusé d'incitation à l'insurrection
concernant les événements du capitole du
6 janvier dernier
si les démocrates se sont tous prononcés
en faveur de sa destitution
seuls sept sénateurs républicains ont
voté contre leur camp un chiffre
insuffisant pour faire tomber donald
trump
mais nous avons vu dans ce sénat
aujourd'hui un groupe de républicains
lâches qui n'ont apparemment pas d'autre
choix parce qu'ils ont peur de défendre
leur travail de respecter l'institution
dans laquelle ils servent prochaine
ouais qu'est ce qui est si important
chez nous qu'est ce qui est si important
dans notre survie politique qui est plus
important que notre constitution que
nous avons fait le serment de protéger
et de défendre
après une première tentative de
destitution de donald trump début 2020
le camp démocrate échoue à nouveau
mais malgré la défaite le parti affirme
que ce second procès n'a pas été inutile
malgré les résultats du vote sur la
condamnation de donald trump devant la
cour de destitution il mérite d'être
condamné
et je crois qu'ils
le sera devant le tribunal de l'opinion
publique il mérite d'être discrédité de
façon permanente et je crois qu'il a été
discrédité aux yeux du peuple américain
et dans le jugement de l'histoire toutes
les pièces à conviction du camp
démocrate n'auront pas suffi à
convaincre la majorité républicaine qui
maintient son soutien à donald trump
directement visé par le discours
incriminé son successeur à la maison
blanche a réagi peu après le verdict
même si le vote final n'a pas abouti à
une condamnation le fonde l'accusation
n'est pas contesté ce triste chapitre de
notre histoire nous a rappelé que la
démocratie est fragile qu'elle doit
toujours être défendue que nous devons
toujours rester vigilant
donald trump restera le seul président
de l'histoire des états unis à être visé
par deux procès en destitution son
second acquittement est donc une
véritable victoire
je n'ai pas de problème avec qui que ce
soit nous avons clôturé le combat dans
cette pièce nous les avons plaqué au sol
et nous avons remporté cette affaire il
n'y a plus de combats
nous avons gagné non coupable de son
côté donald trump s'est félicité du
verdict l'ex-président de 74 ans a même
déjà pris rendez vous avec les
américains promettant on devrait pour la
grandeur du pays sans donner davantage
de détails
innocenté une deuxième fois donald trump
pourrait entre autres de nouveau se
présenter à l'élection présidentielle et
se feront acquittement de donald trump
et bien sûr réagir les américains eco
tech je veux juste montrer a trois
poumons soutien il y a beaucoup de gens
qui aiment regarder sa propriété alors
je me suis dit que s'ils regardent ils
vont voir ça je suis heureux qu'ils
aient été acquittés
vous savez je pense que justice a été
rendue je ne pense pas que ce qui s'est
passé soit de sa faute je pense que
c'était malheureux et j'ai hâte qu'il
revienne
je suis contente je suis heureuse
c'était compliqué ça aurait pu se passer
autrement
pour être honnête je ne suis pas choqué
je pense que peu de gens avaient
l'espoir que cette mise en accusation
aboutissent à sa condamnation l'acteur
était planifié et orchestré et je trouve
très étrange que personne ne veuille
pointé du doigt le président lui même
qui est à bien des égards le meneur mais
je pense que c'est une tendance et
honnêtement je m'y attendais tout ce qui
s'est passé le 6 était fou je pense que
ça va entrer dans l'histoire pour les
pieds raison je crois donc c'était
vraiment nécessaire et je trouve
étonnant la rapidité avec laquelle le
procès s'est terminé
les etats unis s'inquiètent des premiers
éléments de l'enquète mené à abu crâne
en chine par l' oms sur l'origine de la
pandémie
les investigations se sont achevées
mercredi sans conclusion définitive
washington et le ms demandent à pékin de
fournir plus d'informations écoutez
peter berg en baraque
il est l'un des enquêteurs dépêchés sur
place nous voulons plus de données nous
avons demandé plus de données et nous
espérons que cela fera partie de la
phase 2 des études que nous poursuivons
dans les prochaines semaines donc oui un
mélange de frustration mais aussi un
mélange d'attentes réaliste le liban est
lancé aujourd'hui sa campagne de
vaccination contre le colis de 19 hier
28 mille 500 doses du vaccin father
biotech sont arrivés sur place d'autres
devraient suivre un soulagement dans ce
pays est confronté à de multiples crises
en quoi cela avec à pierre pissavy
yvernault il est officiellement le
premier libanais à se faire vacciner
contre le coc vie 19 lui elle c'est le
docteur mahmoud hassoun chef du service
de soins intensifs de l'hôpital rafic
hariri au sud de beyrouth
dès ce dimanche le liban lance sa
campagne de vaccination sont concernés
l'ensemble du personnel médical et les
citoyens de plus de 75 ans
pour le précédent premier ministre est
la vaccination représente une première
étape vers le retour à la vie normale
nous lançons la campagne nationale de
vaccination contre le coc vide 19 avec
des vaccins de haute qualité efficace et
digne de confiance
par la suite nous commencerons à lever
petit à petit les restrictions que cette
pandémie nous a imposé et donc la vie
reprendra dans des secteurs variés
quand nous aurons atteint l'immunité
collective souhaité une chaude
une bonne nouvelle également pour les
hôpitaux du pays
nombre d'entre eux sont saturés le taux
d'occupation soins intensifs est souvent
très élevé une campagne est vécue comme
un véritable soulagement par le
personnel soignant libanais aujourd'hui
nous venons nous faire vacciner
nous sommes vraiment heureux parce que
honnêtement c'est fatigant au travail on
a tout le temps peur chaque patient dont
vous vous approchez pour faire un bilan
de santé
vous ne savez pas s'il est positif au co
vide ou non nous devons toujours prendre
toutes les précautions
donc nous sommes très heureux depuis le
début de l'épidémie
334 milles libanais ont été touchés par
le coni 19 avec près de 4000 morts
avec cette campagne de vaccination le
pays espère désengorger les hôpitaux et
continuer la levée progressive des
restrictions imposées le 8 février
dernier
et pour faire face à aux nouveaux
variants bruxelles va autoriser plus
facilement les vaccins améliorer une
annonce de la commissaire à la santé
dans la presse allemande aujourd'hui
accusé de lenteur dans sa gestion de la
pandémie l'union européenne va donc
accélérer leurs procédures
d'autorisation nous avons examiné le
processus avec l' agence européenne des
médicaments et nous avons maintenant
décider qu'un vaccin qui a été améliorée
par le fabricant sur la base du vaccin
précédent pour lutter contre les
nouvelles mutations ne doit plus passer
par tout le processus d'approbation
il sera donc plus rapide de disposer de
vaccins adaptés sans faire de concession
sur la sécurité
et puis ces nouvelles restrictions en
allemagne depuis eddy
entre minuit et jusqu'au 17 février le
pays ferme ses frontières avec
l'autriche mais aussi la république
tchèque a considéré comme des zones à
hauts risques face à face à la pandémie
les entrées se font au compte-gouttes
même si l union européenne s'oppose un
repli sur soi de ses pays membres on
voit cela avec emil lyng h au poste
frontière de kieffer spelden dans le sud
est du pays
les entrées sont patiemment filtrés par
la police pour pouvoir passer la douane
il faut désormais remplir plusieurs
critères être allemand ou résider en
allemagne mais surtout présenter un test
de dépistage du coc vite 19 récent est
négatif pour cette conductrice
autrichienne c'est la mauvaise surprise
je viens du tyrol je voulais seulement
traverser l'allemagne pour aller à
vienne hier soir j'ai lu que l'on
pouvait transité par l'allemagne avec un
test négatif c'est une catastrophe
j'ai un chien qui a 15 ans dans la
voiture je vais devoir traverser
l'autriche pendant des heures je ne
connais pas le chemin et je n'ai pas de
gps
c'est super les frontaliers mais aussi
des professions considérées comme
stratégiques bénéficie cependant d'une
exception à condition toujours de
présenter un test pcr négatif de
nombreux automobilistes ont dû faire
demi tour
les personnes auxquelles l'entrée est
refusée sont rassemblés avec leurs
voitures
une voiture de police arrive devant le
coup voix et ensemble ils prennent la
route pour retourner en autriche le même
filtrage est effectuée à la frontière
avec la république tchèque
un millier de policiers sont mobilisés
pour assurer ces contrôles
une décision qui n'est pas du goût de
l'union européenne bruxelles redoutent
le chacun pour soi et une remise en
cause de la libre circulation dans
l'espace schengen mais pour l'allemagne
qui pointe la lenteur de la campagne de
vaccination coordonné par bruxelles
priorité est donnée à la sécurité et à
la protection de la population
je pense que nous avons besoin du
soutien de bruxelles maintenant en
particulier en ce qui concerne la
vaccination il
il ya beaucoup de travail à faire
bruxelles peut apporter une contribution
importante pour tout cela ici à la
frontière c'est ce que font la police
fédérale et celle du land
afin d'obtenir le meilleur résultat
malgré des chiffres de contamination en
baisse en plus de ces restrictions aux
frontières
l'allemagne vient de décider de
maintenir au moins jusqu'au 7 mars
le confinement partielle de sa
population en france la circulation à
des variants le sud africain notamment
inquiète en moselle et dans le nord à
dunkerque les élus locaux réclament la
fermeture des écoles voire 1re
confinement locale mais pour l'instant
le gouvernement s'en tient tout
renforcement des dépistages de la
vaccination avec le maintien des
gestes-barrières dimitri scission depuis
un an le taux d'incidence sert d'outil
pour mesurer la dynamique de l'épidémie
le gouvernement considère que le seuil
d'alerté franchi quand 50 nouveaux cas
sont enregistrés parmi cent mille
habitants en sept jours en moselle
ce chiffre est largement dépassé le
ministre de la santé s'y est rendu ce
vendredi à la rencontre des élus c'est
le corona virus circule en moselle avec
une incidence plus élevée que dans le
reste du territoire de cette région
grand est une incidence qui est proche
des 300 pour cent mille sur une semaine
ce rebond de l'épidémie est due aux
variants brésilien et sud africain il
représente maintenant 40 % des nouvelles
contaminations
suite à la visite d'olivier véran les
élus locaux espéraient obtenir la
fermeture des écoles dans le département
il y avait consensus entre tous les élus
pour lui demander l'avancé des vacances
scolaires à la semaine prochaine c'est à
dire à ce soir après concertation avec
le ministre de l'éducation nationale
jean michel blanquer
le gouvernement a décidé de ne pas
donner suite à cette demande
les écoles resteront ouvertes mais une
classe sera fermée pour dix jours
dès qu'un élève sera testé positif aux
coded pour le maire de metz cette
annonce a eu l'effet d'une douche froide
les bras m'en tombent on imaginait au
moins avoir une réponse positive sur la
fermeture des établissements scolaires
une semaine avant les vacances la
propagation est très importante sur les
10 20 ans mais le gouvernement pratiquer
la politique de l'autruche
j'ai 30 % de personnel extrascolaires en
moi en ce moment à cause du virus
l'hôpital tient au prix de
déprogrammation qui ne cesse de
s'allonger
cet entêtement est incompréhensible la
moselle est frontalière de l'allemagne
et du luxembourg
la base aussi les variants circule ces
deux pays ont décidé de fermer leur
école depuis une semaine pour le
luxembourg
depuis deux mois pour l'allemagne et
pour terminer ebola de retour en guinée
conakry et cinq ans après la fin de la
dernière épidémie dans le pays
aujourd'hui sept cas ont été confirmés
trois personnes sont mortes entre 2013
et 2016 ebola a fait onze mille trois
cents morts en afrique
l' oms a annoncé l'envoi de plusieurs
doses de vaccins contre la fièvre
hémorragique a nation quand cette
nouvelle épidémie va rapidement être
maîtrisée chez l'arsenal est aujourd'hui
plus étendue et nous devons en tirer
profit pour pouvoir s'y reconstruire
cette situation le plus rapidement
possible le ms est alertée à tous les
niveaux au niveau du siège est en lien
avec le fabricant pour que les doses
nécessaires soient mises à disposition
le plus rapidement possible pour aider à
cette riposte et c'est la fin de ce
journal merci à vous de l'avoir suivi on
va se retrouver en direct
trente minutes rester avec nous sur rt
france
[Musique]
il ya à peu près un enfant sur deux en
france qui est soit victime soit hauteur
de cyber violence sur internet un
contenu haineux de quelqu'un qui dit à
une fillette de 8 ans on va te suicider
ça ça doit être retirée immédiatement il
n'ya aucun débat à avoir sur ce retrait
là parce que ça ça fait des suicides la
loi le condamne déjà c'est déjà interdit
de faire ça bien sûr mais c'est juste
que les gaffes à ne l'appliquent pas la
justice est lente et c'est très
problématique qui va prendre ce rôle de
régulateur la loi peut aider l'éducation
peut aider selon les différentes
catégories date